joe don't know that's the focus of
tonight's angle
there's simply no way to spin it at this
point president biden's first foreign
trip
was an unmitigated disaster
even jill's goofy jacket couldn't save
it
time magazine's stupid cover couldn't
frame it
and biden himself well he couldn't
explain it
so he reverted to tedious aphorisms
as that old expression goes the proof of
the pudding is in the eating
proof is in the pudding oh i'd never
heard that before
if there was any doubt about what a
complete flop this was
well that doubt was erased after biden
emerged from his
three-hour meeting with vladimir putin
well he had a
total meltdown with his own com shop
oh sorry i'm at the u.s press corps
are you so confident he'll change his
behavior mr president
what do you do when did i say i was
confident let's get it straight
i said what will change their behavior
is that the rest of the world reacts to
them
diminishes their standing in the world
we denied any involvement in cyber
attacks
so how does that account to a
constructive meeting as president
president
shockingly caitlyn collins posed a
common sense question
in other words he was trying to get at
what incentive is there
for putin to stop cyber attacks on the
united states
well the answer of course is zero under
joe biden
because biden speaks softly and carries
the equivalent of a big
foam pool noodle there's no there there
and everyone knows it because even if
you're a rank
partisan you see that these meetings
require
real expertise because they're are real
consequences to being outmaneuvered
which biden was
what concrete evidence do you have
from these three year hour three plus
hours that suggests that any movement
has been made
and i don't know i don't i don't mean
that no no no no no no i know but
you're all questions look to be a good
reporter you got to be negative you got
to have a negative view of life okay it
seems to me
the way you all you never ask a positive
question
is he kidding is fine kidding he's been
in washington since leonid brezhnev was
the leader of the ussr
and he's now just realizing that the
media like to get the kick the hornet's
nest every
now and again plus let's not forget that
what is it 99.9
of the reporters on that tarmac voted
for biden
and practically campaign for him and
then masqueraded as reporting about him
now forget apologizing to cnn biden
should have apologized to the american
people
biden rolled over for the europeans and
today
he let vladimir putin run circles around
him
right down to putin's using democrat
talking points
about america's race and crime problem
in american cities every day people are
killed
that includes the leaders of various
organizations
you can't say a word about you you don't
have time to say a word and somebody is
killed
i remember that somebody ran away and
was shot in the back for example
well i guess joe and vlad they did agree
on one thing america's systemically
racist right
well the fact is any honest observer
knows that
if anyone knows even a tiny bit about
foreign affairs
has to concede that this entire trip
ended up being a
complete waste of time and government
resources
i was thinking about this today next
time we should just save everybody's
time and just
send a notary over there to sign
whatever documents europe puts in front
of us oh it'll be done
but remember this has always been the
joe biden that we knew and some of you
came to love
he's always been more interested in
being pals with people
than ever making waves even when making
waves
is what's required to deliver results
for the american people
remember even before the summit began it
was obvious that biden was just no match
for the former kgb intel officer
it's one thing calling putin a killer
when the guy's 5 000 miles away in the
kremlin
but what about face to face
vladimir putin laughed at the suggestion
that you had called him
a killer is that still your belief sir
that he is a killer
answer the first question i'm laughing
too
they actually uh
well look i mean he has made clear that
uh
uh that was just excruciating
and it gets worse every time you watch
it he also picked up that annoying
laugh reflex that harris has whenever
she's asked a hard question
this whole thing about the border we've
been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
borders are so funny well tonight
america is not laughing
joe biden is incapable of sitting across
the table from any competent world
leader
and he's certainly not able to convince
him to change his mind on any
significant issue
in the lead-up to this trip the white
house took great pains though to remind
everyone that biden would be turning the
page
on the trump's america first approach
things would go back to normal pundits
gleefully pronounced
where we work with the world community
and don't sit around just thumping our
chess
but the fact is in international
negotiations effective leaders
always work to advance and safeguard
their own country's national interests
until now at least the fact is biden
doesn't know how to get tough
he's a guy who's simply most comfortable
being
everybody's friend so all you need to do
is put him in a situation where he has
to choose between getting along with
other people
or making them necessarily uncomfortable
well he's going to choose the friendship
route every single time that might be
nice in a hallmark movie but not here
but trump didn't care about making
people uncomfortable not when it came to
protecting american prosperity
and national security this is the b
team as we've told you all along under
trump we had real intellects like bob
lighthizer for trade
steve mnuchin at treasury and mike
pompeo
at state he'll join us in a few moments
but now we have people in charge
who pretty much couldn't get top jobs in
any other administration except this one
biden and his team went to europe and
they got
zero tangible benefits for america they
resolved the boeing airbus dispute by
simply caving to france boeing got
shafted
of course boeing's gonna biden's gonna
say oh we got language on china
it's great here's one problem the
language on china is so weak
that the europeans aren't bound in any
meaningful way by it
and china really isn't affected at all
the commitment is basically just that we
should all keep pursuing a conversation
with china big deal
china dominates while you try to
dialogue
china wasn't even specifically singled
out in any of the human rights
paragraphs it was all kind of bland and
meaningless
in international diplomacy words matter
and over the past week
the angle has taken you through the
nitty-gritty and you now know that china
got off scot-free
the nato communique referred to china as
a challenge
but russia as a threat even that was no
big deal though since
russia got their nordstream 2 pipeline
while america got higher energy prices
across the board
here's the bottom line putin is thrilled
with this summit
don't take my word for it here's russian
chess grand master and putin opponent
gary kosperov putin got what he wanted
that's why he was beaming with joy when
he left uh
press um the the summit and went to the
press conference
the europeans are celebrating
and china is completely comfortable
now if obama's first foreign policy trip
was the equivalent of an apology tour
biden's was a surrender tour
as a result of his efforts going forward
europe will be in the driver's seat
china will probably take taiwan our
southern border is going to just remain
wide open
in russia they'll be able to hack us at
will
if the democrats were a functional party
that really cared about putting our
interests first
they never never would have nominated
biden in the first place the man
is totally in over his head and always
has been
since his days in the senate since he
ran for president
in 1988 he's always been the punchline
but now unfortunately for us america is
as well and that's the angle